eu na verdade sempre falo que tem uma
dívida com o são sebastião o início da
minha carreira enquanto arqueólogo foi
nessa cidade em que o ato já há 25 anos
e os sonhos de arqueólogo joão vi muita
gente falando que gostaria de ser que
óleo e encanta é essa área essa
profissão eu não sei por que cargas
d'água o primeiro momento pensei em
fazer apologia na minha vida foi aos 12
anos de idade quando estava na 6ª série
a professora pergunta pra um monte de
alunos que queria ser médico engenheiro
e por aí adiante perguntaram era muito
mirradinho mais do que sou hoje o estado
de subnutrição quase que completo e
falei que queria ser que órgão foi uma
tremenda gargalhadas na sala toda é
mesmo porque eu não tinha idéia
o que era aquilo a princípio achava que
mexer com fósseis um de noção mais o
passar do tempo essa coisa veio batendo
demais na minha cabeça de uma forma
muito intensa eu acabei lendo um livro
que eu recomendo chamado deuses túmulos
sábios foi um dos primeiros livros de
arqueologia antes tem um eram os deuses
astronautas de eric bana dany com a
teoria toda que a gente foi visitar por
extraterrestres me perdoem aqueles que
acreditam mas com o passar do tempo a
gente foi amadurecendo e eu acabei no
final dos anos 80 conhecendo
efetivamente o que era arqueologia e de
uma forma um tanto quanto arrogante de
salto alto achando que o arqueólogo que
a tecnologia era ciência conhecedora de
toda a verdade a verdade o início foi em
são josé dos campos e foi uma grande
decepção no início da carreira leva com
sepultamento escravo pratas uma grande
prova coletiva de escravos do século 19
e quando começava meu mestrado uma
empresa com medo de perder a terra
meteu uma retroescavadeira gigantesca
essa cova e o que eram os sepultamentos
viraram fragmentos e mais fragmentos
embora muita gente não saiba foi aí que
eu vim para são sebastião totalmente
desiludido sentado em uma praça de uma
grande amiga patrícia viviane
nesse momento ela me fala de um lugar
aqui assombrado conhecido como morro da
senzala temido por grande parte da
população local
conheci um outro rapaz que foi o grande
incentivador neto de sebastião fortunato
já falecido também tanto sebastião
quanto neto e que me levou no lugar
fantástico que é o sítio arqueológico
são francesco totti é a grande recepção
linha e talvez de vocês quando pensa em
arqueologia harrison ford e de repente
tem essa figura em estado de subnutrição
completo é talvez quase que o arqueólogo
da etiópia o chicote talvez lançava
todos os estagiários que começaram
comigo no início da carreira e pouco a
pouco fui descobrindo que a tecnologia
tinha aventura tinha todo esse contexto
maravilhoso encerrar além disso ela
tinha que ter uma abordagem não
classifica como um grande colecionador
de objetos tal qual no século 19 quer
acatar vasos potes e colocaram este
museu em que tinha uma etiqueta eu sou o
penico da dona maria leopoldina eu sou o
wagner parabéns pico e daí o que me vale
o objeto pelo objeto importante as
pessoas por trás de cada um dos objetos
eu não posso falar em arqueologia
navegaria e rompendo com a massa mais
uma vez de quem gosta de velho é
reumatismo quem gosta de velho é museu
isso a gente tem que romper e tampouco a
idéia de que eu estou estudando passado
para viver melhor o presente ou prever o
futuro primeiro passado já foi o futuro
só se for pai de santo uma bola de
cristal para ver o que acontece
única exclusivamente existe uma função
conhecer as nós mesmos
vivenciar o presente
crescendo isso eu iniciei esse o
trabalho no sítio arqueológico são
francisco que é isso aqui
quem conhece o sítio hoje ver o que era
isso no começo no meio do matagal e aí
nesse momento o início iniciou todo o
trabalho e vem uma história interessante
sebastião um farto neto é o grande
responsável disso a quem eu vou dedicar
essa apresentação me dizer o seguinte e
foi ele que me levou até lá meu filho
esse lugar tinha como proprietário
sujeito chamado joaquim pedro ele tinha
uma grande quantidade de escravos que
pode ser tão rico ele fez um pacto com o
capeta enfiou coisa ruim dentro de uma
garrafinha ea partir daí ele começa a
ter uma grande quantidade de escravos
enriquece horas
um belo dia a mulher embaixo da cama a
sua garrafa solta rolhas liberto coisa
ruim e shopping pedro estrebucha aqui no
canal de são sebastião e levado para ser
velado
lá na casa grande no sítio são francisco
no momento em que ele está sendo levado
o bce um grande estrondo as paredes se
ajoelham vem o capeta das profundezas do
inferno e levam joaquim pedro uma
passagem de ida sem volta
a estrutura toda vez que o velho ou
sebastião fortunato me falava sobre isso
eu ria e achava que era uma tremenda
bombeiros passaram se mais de 15 anos
para descobrir que o que a gente tem
aqui
todo esse conjunto arquitetônico de rara
beleza
um dos mais importantes patrimônios
culturais do país e que pertencem a são
sebastião em que guarda mitos como a
história dos dois pombinhos da louça
inglesa retratando o amor de uma
princesa por um plebeu e transformados
em 21 jogos mostrados na faia ansa
inglesa lenta dos dois pombinhos tinham
na verdade um grande fundo de verdade
passaram se mais de 15 anos para
descobrir seu gastando tempo e dinheiro
pra descobrir que na verdade tudo aquilo
que o fortunato falava
é verdade embora no sentido figurado
joaquim pedro existe um era um pobre
coitado
em 1830 e se casa com a filha de elite
ana de souza cunha escobar com 13 anos
de idade engravidada por joaquim pedro
se casa no domingo às 6 horas da manhã
aqui numa 3 sem nenhum parente às
escondidas
isso é uma vergonha para a família e
passaram a viver lá em cima nas ruínas
do sítio arqueológico são francisco a
partir desse momento joaquim pedro que
não tinha dinheiro nem começa a
enriquecer o dito popular quem não tem
nada enriquece muito rápido a fez pacto
com coisa ruim
olha esse shopping pedro era apontado
como demoníaco pela igreja porque por
trás de toda a simbologia do sítio se
esconde um cristão novo se esconde o
judeu e que era repudiado pelo
catolicismo em toda a simbologia como o
lírio de som bruno se esconde na verdade
a estrela de davi fora tanta outra
simbologia que o meu caso eu vim
demonstrar aqui
joaquim pedro em cima existiu é a
certidão de casamento se casa com ana
cunha de souza escobar filha da elite já
que o pedro além de tudo é um excelente
artista em seu início em desenho de
joaquim pedro aos 15 anos de idade já
apaixonado pela futura esposa dona cunha
de souza desenho e joaquim pedro
sebastião fortunato
olha eu falei que ouviu se um grande
estrondo e e as paredes se ajoelharam de
fato existe uma barragem em um sítio no
momento de decadência a água estoura
barragem esse volume da água bate nas
paredes e as paredes efetivamente se
ajoelham enfim no sentido figurado
sebastião fortunato tinha
toda a razão isso me deu uma grande
lição
hoje eu trabalho no brasil inteiro
fazendo a tecnologia já há mais de 25
anos
eu aprendi uma grande coisa eu não vou
num sítio arqueológico eu vou na
comunidade
a comunidade é detentora do verdadeiro
conhecimento é a comunidade que sabe o
que é o seu património de fato e nós de
qualquer área do conhecimento temos que
saber ouvir a comunidade e o saber-fazer
popular porque acima de tudo onde há
fumaça há fogo
meu muito obrigado a todos